i would like you to look at this chair
oh i looked at it okay
it's
in jizz
yeah like it's not a bit no it really it
there's jizz
[Applause]
that that is either like a bird came in
here
and came all over the chair
that's as likely as an owl killing
kathleen peterson have a seat i was just
gonna make oh
you knew i was gonna say that i was
gonna say that joke also did you like
have the experience i had which is i
didn't even know there were people up in
the balcony until jon hamm walked out
and then a whole crew
yeah those are the ham fans
they got ham price tickets that's half
price
just bring any slice of ham to any show
that i'm appearing on you getting free
ham makes everything better ham is
delicious and it makes everything better
and you're welcome yeah that's right
john john hamm port
port
[Laughter]
i want to say up top i'm sorry for
asking you to sit in jizz
um i'm also seated in jizz well good i
mean if we're all doing it yeah and by
the way don't look at your seats
yeah this is like a reverse it's the top
of the seat horrible oprah everybody got
jizz tonight exactly and you get to see
you
you get to sit in jail oh no
dirty oprah oh dirty oprah
here's my here's my first question what
if that was her first like take on being
oprah
her first what just like like a weird
like colin sleazy friends show like it
was dirty oprah and it didn't really hit
and people were like i get what you're
going for but this is probably not what
you should be doing let's flip the whole
script and be like super pleasant
all right
people forget that oprah started as like
a shock
like you want to meet dr phil you want
to see his balls
hey whoa oprah
no he teach us to meditate he's a
clerical
have you done oprah have i been on oprah
i have i didn't ask you okay
what
no no i'm asking
uh take it as you will have you done
oprah
have you been on oprah
wait
it's not getting any less dirty let me
hold on have you been on top of oprah i
figure that's exactly what you meant and
no i have not yet i haven't had the
pleasure no yes that's steadman man
that's what you want that's a no ham
zone this is a no
for real
maybe gail listen
oh
dear
that's that's a good question do you
like being jon hamm is it fun i think a
lot of people would be like i'd love to
be john hamm or are there times when
you're like [__] i wish i could hang up
my head somewhere and just be uh one of
these guys angry
like i pick one of you just like for
being not john him like this piece of
[__]
look at this piece of [__] ain't no one
clamoring
no selfies i'm sorry what's your name
jason you're the king james center mason
which one was it because or is it pork
jason
he pulled down the mask he wanted that
whole ham absolutely jason yeah
he wanted unprotected ham on ham gays
um but for real do you ever go like [__]
it would be more convenient to not be
john hammond i know no it's it is you
know not for nothing it was like work i
worked very hard to get where i am in my
career in life and everything i feel
very lucky certainly that i've found
success much later than most yeah uh and
i also am very like someone say you
haven't found it yet but somewhere
i'm still mad about the port thing but
keep going
but let me ask you that here's another
one here have some ibm when you walk
into a party everyone knows uh they like
probably people want a piece of that
sweet sweet ham right yeah maybe i'm not
sure you know i haven't really had that
that experience so much i mostly go to
you know parties with people i know so a
yeah i don't really go to like a
that's not a party that's a soiree for
sure i'm talking about like you walk
into you rust again
which you can do now again which you can
do i think they were open the whole time
for sure they were like i don't know
just go on the side door nobody doesn't
know and it's the front it pounces off
the side you'll be fine there's much
worse in that bar than
like
these chairs are clean compared to
what's on
on offer you can get covered 20 at ye
rest again right now
i know a guy you can get covered like
15.
i have like vintages yeah oh my god your
coveted uh sommelier comes up he's like
tell me what you want i'll breathe it
right on you yeah i'm feeling nostalgic
could i have covered 21.
i'm going to say it to you i i miss
covet 15. i'll say it
it was a different time
trump wasn't president yet there was
like a whole difference it's you know it
felt like a more
more fun way to you know yeah lose your
breath i judge history
lose your breath i die it was cute it
was you oh lose your breath
uh from memory how much of john's ham
jon hamm can you remember
very little uh i remember i remember
doing that sketch and thinking like well
this is never going to make it on the
air
but somebody in the prop department
built a toilet paper roll out of ham
that has a piece of ham that rolls off
of it so i was like well maybe i can
keep it
did you keep it i did not no it
certainly wouldn't keep
you can't keep it
by the end of the after party it's
probably you probably don't want it gets
that weird green shimmery you know oh
yeah no everybody knows no no disrespect
to your namesake but ham is one of the
wetter slimy it is a wet it's a wet meat
yeah like would you rather be john
turkey that's a fair question maybe a
salami like a cured
yeah
mommy
yeah a prosciutto maybe
that just means ham
ah
i got friends like this whole thing
when you walk around the streets of rome
as i'm assuming you do this is what i do
all the time and people scream hey
exactly what happens you have a [__] all
brown like that sort of thing
not now but like dirty oprah hey
and then they
get on the bus off they go they know the
bit they've listened to this podcast
when she was directed at the beginning
dr phil's bomb like colin sleazy friends
the cable access no one remembers is
this voice okay
i don't know
how much longer where
they hit
joke's on you ham was first oh don't
worry you're so cute no no welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome so
john's handling the chains on your chair
it's uh we didn't do it they were there
yeah
we were the whole
knowing jizz it always it's like an
appetite it comes back he never you know
doesn't stay hidden for long
oh my god
it's so great to be here at the end of
both of our careers
don't know about the future it's
anybody's guess joey lawrence comes off
and says whoa you can't
you can't have italian you can't even do
[Laughter]
oh me
[Music]